what's up everybody welcome to part 17
of our practical Flast tutorial video
series in this video we're my finishing
up this registration form so let's go
ahead and get into it so first of all
come on down to actually let's go to the
very top we're going to give a few more
imports
so from WT forums we've imported form
but we're going to need some of the
other things that we called so that when
you form billion field a text field
password field and Valladares so make
sure you have those otherwise we would
be in trouble so now we're going to go
ahead and do save that and then now the
only other things that we we need here
is we need this register to HTML page so
let's go ahead and make our register to
HTML page so coming over to our
directories here template and let's just
duplicate one of these and then we're
going to call it register dot HTML cool
and actually before we get into that I
want to show you guys a little
something-something
so let's say in your script um let's say
we just delete validators for now from
the imports and we'll save that now what
if we come over here um and we go sudo
RS to service Apache to restart if we
come over to our website now and we
refresh the website we're going to find
that we have an internal server error so
basically a 500 error and we have
absolutely no idea why and and so this
is obviously a problem the way that you
can find out what the air actually is is
by running the init dot pi so you could
do Python underscore in it dot pi run
that and then we'll come down here and
we'll see well first of all okay this
was the problem as a trailing comma but
we can fix that really quick let's fix
that comma problem and let's run it one
more time
okay now you get a validators error or a
name error that validators is not
defined so now we know that oh we're
missing that parameter so we can add
validators save that and we can run in
it dot pi one more time and we can see
now it's actually running on the
localhost so we're all good so we call
ctrl C to stop that and we're good to go
so now we'll do service Apache to
restart restart Apache we'll come over
to I don't know what happened to our
website let's just bring it up again and
we actually it's loading so uh so we fix
that so anyways that's how you can kind
of find out why you're getting maybe a
500 error that you're not sure about so
now we're going to do is we're going to
duplicate that we already yet we already
duplicated so let me bring that over
here so we open up our registrar data
HTML page we'll leave the block body
stuff but we'll get rid of that 500 yo
and we'll go ahead and work on this page
so in the block body what are we gonna
have well we need our body tags as usual
so we'll add the body tags body slash
body and we're good there now we're
going to make a div so div class equals
and this will just be a container
container close off that div tag before
we forget tab that over because it's
part of our body here and so we've got
that now we're going to add some h4 here
so heading for and we'll say register
cool we'll add a break just for like a
line break there and then now we're
going to import something and this is
going to actually we're going to need
another HTML page but that's okay so
from underscore form helpers HTML and
that needs to be around or in quotes
from form helpers a HTML we want to
import render underscore field and then
now we'll save that and that would be a
probably a good time to do form helpers
so let's just take register well
duplicate that
and we're going to duplicate it to be
underscore form form helpers HTML so
we've duplicated that let's open that up
really quick let me bring that down here
and in fact let me zoom into both of
these since I bet they're kind of hard
to see as I type so there's that pause
here if you have any patrocle following
along up to that point
coming over to form helpers now 4mm form
helpers is actually just being imported
it doesn't need to extend any template
but it is going to be a macro so macro
render field and then in parentheses
that's going to be field and then we
have some more code and actually I'm
thinking we'll we'll just copy and paste
this code so let me do this copy and
paste so what's happening here is where
this is just the HTML with the variables
so we've got the label this one is going
to be called safe for the password so
username password if there are any
errors we're going to spit out all of
the errors and we're just going to get
through all the labels basically and so
macro is our Jinja templating ability to
do any sort of a basically script sort
sort of thing and then render field
that's for flask and then what field are
we rendering we're rendering field so
let's save that and then we'll come back
over to our register page and but every
time I post the videos the code should
be made available if for whatever reason
this code is not made available it's not
very long you can pause it here and copy
it if you'd like or post a comment ask
me to post the code this just would take
a really not really long but it'd be a
waste of time I think so
so there's that and moving back over to
register so that's what's happening here
we're importing that code and now we're
going to make this form so now we have
form tag form and this form method the
method of this form is going to
host and the action of this is going to
be register page so when they submit its
going to submit on register page and
that's where we're going to have the
register page basically asking if there
was a post so that's why the action of
this form is actually just sending them
to register and eventually if they
happen if everything checks out it will
be redirected to another page so uh now
we'll use tab over once and we'll say D
L and then slash DL and then now we have
all the parameters of this basically
form and we have user name email
password password and then they have to
accept the Terms of Service so basically
five so one two three four five now
we're going to render underscore field
what is what is that that's going to be
formed that username and then again and
in fact let's just copy and paste this
because we're basically rendering a lot
of fields so that render field render
feel during a field run field so formed
by user name form dot email form dot
password
let's word spelled correctly form dot
confirm and these are uh like password
confirm all that that's in relation to
where are we here we are this right here
right this is the confirm this is
confirmed password email these are
basically the IDS of those fields form
dot confirm and then form dot accept
underscore TOS okay now uh we never
ended our form so we're going to need to
do that but also we need one more thing
just outside of the DL there we're going
to add paragraph tags P in /p and um
we're going to have this be input and
the type whoops
needs to be a tag input and the type is
equal to what's now that submit and
value equals register okay so that's our
submission and then now we'll close off
the form slash form so that's our whole
form and then we're going to have some
Jinja templating logic and that's going
to be if error so if that error variable
is populated with anything basically is
what if errors asks if there's nothing
to error it'll be none that means false
basically so that's won't run and then
you always want to just end if before
you forget because you python folk are
probably not used to needing to end your
logic statements like that so if there
isn't here we're going to say p class
equals error and then strong like this /
strong and we'll say the error : and
then after the strong tags will do the
error variable and then we'll close off
whoops
close off paragraph tag there so if
error we're going to say air and what
the error actually is okay and that's
basically it that's all we need for our
registration page let's make sure
everything is being closed off here
looks good to me
so let's save that and let's restart
Apache just to be safe but I don't think
we'll actually need to since everything
we did up to this point was just HTML
stuff and we'll come over to our page
moment of truth hopes are low oh we got
a registration page okay so there we
have it and let's go ahead and test if
we have any errors I'll probably
continue those on the next one let's
test it so we'll say the username is
Python the email addresses test at
gmail.com test whoops password
I believe we didn't I can't remember if
we put limits on the password or not
where's our in it right there are
actually no limits on password in theory
I suppose you have to have something
typed in the password but otherwise
you're all set so we will make the
password like out of five and five and I
accept the Terms of Service let's
register and int type of long has no
lens so that's uh in reference to here
remember it was int um so let's let's
just see what the original code let's
see if that works I just still I thought
that I'm pretty sure it's a typo but uh
anyway we'll just refresh confirm the
foreign resubmission and thank you for
registering so now we're there in theory
uh now I'm curious what do we make it
was Python so let's go to sign up one
more time let's go username is Python
email address is test at gmail.com past
four five five I accept register and
thank you Wow okay I guess I guess I was
smart back then I just this doesn't make
sense to me like in X X maybe it returns
the length first
I don't know anyway oh great so let's
add let's register one more user and
then we'll actually we will check that
because I just don't believe it anyway
Python to password password register and
in fact let's check our other things too
so we'll sign up and let's do Python 3
let's do an email address of test test
let's do password 5 password 6 let's
accept the Terms of Service register and
then it says passwords must match ok
cool that worked out so let's do 6 6 but
not accept the Terms of Service register
this field is required so the
registration I accept terms of services
required so let's hit that let's do
let's just do PYT instead of anything
else let's do 5 oops 5 5 register and
field must be between 4 and 20
characters long awesome
okay Python 3 then test at gmail.com
let's just do test or te 5 oops actually
fauna5
and let's just do yetiz fine so we just
this is length parameter register film
us between 6 and 50 okay so it looks
like our registration is working
decently obviously the email address
could be this not even an @ right
register and that would be acceptable so
you might want to have some logic that
requires them to use a legitimate email
address something like that
but this should be fine for now just for
simple stuff uh try think if they really
think there's anything else major I want
to show you so now let's go over here
and we want to access our database I
think how far back our database code was
before there it is nice so my sequel - -
user equals root - p4 password enter and
here I've entered my database now we
need to use use Python program semicolon
change your database and then now we'll
run selects Paul from users
okay so this returns all of our user
information you can see actually here is
our fancy passwords so remember we
actually hashed all passwords
immediately so these are the fancy
passwords saved into our database we
have other information we've got you
basically user ID one two three that's
working awesome user ID username this is
their password their email and then
settings is null for now because we
didn't do anything and everyone has
completed the introduction to Python
programming okay so that's all set we've
got registration working now of course
we need to work on the actual login and
how does that work but before we get to
login I do want to show you guys the how
the password hashing works because
actually it won't equal it won't look
just like this it will be different
numbers so our different hash I suppose
so I'll show you guys how that's
actually working so I think it's
fascinating and you should obviously
know how it works and see how it works
so you can know what's good password
because you can hash passwords all day
but you can have huge hash tables and
find out exactly what someone's password
is very fast so there's a very special
way to do it and so we'll be talking
about that in the next video
but anyways looks like our registration
is working awesome nothing I really need
to add I don't think at the moment for
registration still interested in X that
just is fascinating to me okay since
that works I maybe the first thing and X
is the length on anyway because later on
you can reference the data in X so X and
then you've got I guess probably what's
happening is to normally what you would
do is X dot fetch fall and that would be
all of the data that's in X or you can
do like fetch one stuff like that but
anyway more on those fetching and all
that later so I guess that was the right
code save that let's exit let's restart
Apache one last time make sure I didn't
screw anything up come back to our
website refresh let's register one more
user test at gmail
five accept and actually as you recall a
lot of our passwords were fought like we
I used five five and only six six I
think for the last user this is a
password of five five and this is a
password of five five so actually they
were created a different hash so then
how do you compare those two crazy
anyways that's it for this video if you
have any questions or comments please
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support the subscriptions in
until next time